un día histórico para la comunidad lgtb
en singapur 15 años después del último
debate sobre la posible derogación de la
ley que penaliza las relaciones sexuales
entre hombres el primer ministro lee
hsien loong cumplió con sus promesas
esta vez en su discurso político anual
el gobierno de drogar a la sección 37 7a
y despenalizar a el sexo entre hombres
creo que esto es lo correcto algo que la
mayoría de los singapurenses aceptar
ahora
la ley herencia del dominio colonial
británico prevé una pena máxima de dos
años de prisión a hombres que tengan
relaciones sexuales con otros hombres en
la práctica no se aplica pero para sus
partidarios el texto priva a los
miembros de la comunidad gay de sus
derechos en esta ciudad de estado
conservador a varios intentos de anular
la ley habían fracasado durante los
últimos años en contraste con la
situación de los derechos de los
homosexuales en asia en taiwán el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
es legal desde 2019 y en índia el sexo
entre hombres está despenalizado desde
2018 por lo tanto el anuncio fue bien
recibido por varias asociaciones
la despenalización no sólo mejorará la
vida de las personas lgtb pumas y sus
familias sino que traerá otros
beneficios claros para los negocios el
comercio y la reputación internacional
de singapur lo que hace que este anuncio
sea bienvenido en muchos frentes
pero el primer ministro de singapur
también anunció que proteger a la
concepción del matrimonio entre un
hombre y una mujer definida por la ley
el gobierno enmendar a pronto la
constitución para que el matrimonio
civil siga estando dedicado únicamente a
la unión de dos personas de diferentes
sexos